a woman who accused justice Brett
Kavanaugh of rape has admitted she made
it all up when investigators confronted
left-wing activist Judy Monroe Layton
she admitted it was all just a ploy to
stop the nomination it nearly ruined a
man and his family which is easy to do
when one entire party rejects due
process all you need is a postcard to
Dianne Feinstein it's easier than
registering to vote chuck Grassley has
referred this creep for a criminal
prosecution as well as Julius sweat Nick
you remember her and her horrible lawyer
Michael a vanetti for also making false
claims to investigators now it's
important that all of these people get
what's coming to them
after due process of course because what
they did to Cavanaugh could be done to
you it's also despicable how much press
the allegation got versus the press it
isn't getting now once it's debunked
which then raises another key question
if the Democrats actually believed in
these charges
why aren't they pursuing them now I mean
so what if the guy got confirmed why
stopped justice
why aren't they presenting evidence and
more witnesses could it be they knew the
charges were false from the start could
it be they were willing to stand by a
false smear that would destroy multiple
lives just to score a political win you
know the answer and you better remember
it on Tuesday